so for those of you that have been
following this channel for some time you
probably have a pretty good idea of all
the various different tools that I like
to use when I'm writing code I like to
use Windows as my preferred development
platform I like to use Visual Studio as
my preferred development environment
whether that be for C++ or C sharp and
there's one other tool that I like to
use and something that I've been using
for years ever since I started working
at EA and I had to start writing some
serious C++ code I was introduced to
this tool and I've been using it ever
since in fact I would say that I
probably wouldn't even want to write C++
code without having this tool installed
and what it is is an extension for
visual studio called visual assist
visual assist is a plug-in that makes
your life a whole lot easier and more
efficient when you're working with C++
code c-sharp but really anything inside
Visual Studio it's something that I've
been an absolutely huge fan of it's
something that I've talked about a lot
when I used to livestream like four or
five years ago I absolutely loved visual
assist and I've even joked about them
sponsoring my videos because of how much
love I constantly pour out towards them
and they have this is a video sponsored
by visual assist which is like
absolutely fine by me because I have
been endorsing visual assist for so long
they've reached out to me and they've
asked me to make some videos for you
guys talking about all the various
benefits the visual assist can have for
you and your projects and so today we're
going to be talking about my personal 5
favorite features of visual assist there
might even be like a little sixth one in
there as well for someone that has been
using visual assist for over five years
I just want to say that even though this
is a sponsored video these are my five
favorite features these are not like you
know some lists that I was given it's
nothing like that
this these are my favorite features that
I have been constantly using for the
last five years so let's jump in and
take a look so the first feature that I
want to show you guys is the open file
dialog now this is a really simple
feature honestly I feel like something
like this should be in Visual Studio
just a really quick way to open any file
in your solution just by just by quickly
typing in the name of the file or
searching for it so alt shift or does
that individual assess and you can see
it immediately opens very quickly this
open file in solution dialog I can start
typing in the name of any file like for
example texture and you can see it will
come up here I can quickly use the arrow
keys to navigate to the one I want and
just press ENTER and I've opened the
file that's it I can get back to where I
was before edit Alea it's really fast
and it just works now to compare this to
visual Studios way of doing things we
have this solution Explorer here and I
can just navigate here or I can search
there's there also is a shortcut ctrl
and semicolon if I press that and start
typing in like texture for example it is
gonna actually search the contents of
the files as well you can see it's
rubbish you can change this to not
search within file contents or within
external items a lot of people do that
but still trying to find exactly what I
want
clicking on it it's it's quite it's
quite tedious compared to just alt shift
oh you know it's got a frame buffer
there it is really easy to do no problem
at all I absolutely love this feature
and I use it all the time the actual
search algorithm is also pretty good you
don't have to type in the exact name of
what you're looking for I can just type
F buff for example and it will try and
match everything that either has an F in
it and the word buff so altogether just
a really really easy tool to use and
super super useful similar to this we
have something called find symbol now to
use find symbol we can press alt shift S
and you can see it opens this dialog
here but we can start typing in the name
of any symbol now this can be a macro it
can be a like a static variable it can
be a class or a struct any symbol
whatsoever so for example I have a bunch
of logging macros which begin with like
ages that core if I type in age that
core you can see all of these logging
macros are now here and I can click on
any one I want and I'm taken to the
definition here where I can see what all
of them are this is really useful and if
you uncheck the show only symbols
finding current solutions you can really
search all the symbols that are coming
in externally as well so for example the
infamous like min and Max
definitions there they are you can see
how quick that was as well here it is
men its defined inside men win death and
I can easily see by reading this code
that if I define norm in Maxwell I won't
get those definitions this would have
taken so long to find with our visual
assist if I want to find a specific
class as well it's super simple I can
just type in the name of the class such
as material instance now you can see
there's a lot of stuff coming up here I
can actually limit this to symbols
defining the current solution and also
only classes trucks and namespaces and
you can see that it just immediately
comes up here if I open it I can see my
class maybe I want to search for like
texture 2d or OpenGL texture 2d these
are all classes that are stored in one
file with each other so OpenGL tanks are
cube for example I store in the same
file so I can't just type in texture 2d
to open the actual class inside the Open
File dialog searching for symbols like
that is super useful because I can see
exactly where everything is defined you
can see this one for example is inside
single age but it's super simple to find
with fine symbol and also since
everything inside hazel is inside this
hazel namespace I can easily just search
just for hazel here and if I just search
for hazel it's gonna find everything
that belongs to that namespace I can
look at every single class or struct
that is inside hazel in this nice little
view here which honestly is amazing when
you're in a large file like editor layer
they'll see Bibi it's really useful to
see all of the different methods or
functions that you have inside this
actual file now you could look at the
header file alt or by the way a
fantastic shortcut to quickly switch
between header files and implementation
files but it's still a little bit messy
to kind of sort through all of this code
and try and find everything you're
looking for
that's why we have alt em now alt M will
bring down this drop-down which you can
also just click here and it will show
you all of the different namespaces and
functions and methods and all of our
stuff inside this file and the best part
is you can actually just start typing
whatever you want and it will obviously
search for that so I can type in attach
and you can see it comes up here
this is great because if I'm navigating
through a file and I'm lost and I want
to for example jump to the update
function I could just hit alt M type in
an update and hit enter
and you can see I'm exactly there and
it's just so so so easy and quick now
since we're on the topic of navigation
there is also alt G and alt G is
goto definition is very similar to
visual studios f12 it's just that
instead of immediately going to it and
being also quite slow in a lot of cases
all GE tells you all of the
possibilities here all of the overloads
and then you can easily pick which one
you want to jump to this is super useful
because a lot of the time I might not
want to jump exactly to the definition
so if I hit f12 on on update for example
I'm taking straight over here into the
definition but if I hit alt Chi I can
choose whether or not I want the header
file or the CPP file super useful and I
found that it's a lot more reliable than
visual studios f12 it almost never makes
a mistake and it's also generally a lot
faster although to be fair visual
studios f12 has actually come a long way
since like visuals for your 2015 where
it was just unbearably slow but visual
assist I think is still faster and
finally the last feature I want to show
you is something that is super useful
when you're writing a new class over
here I've got a player dot H and play it
on CPP file which is a pretty typical
set up I'm going to create a new class
called player and I'll fill it in with
some basic functions and as you can see
I would now have the fairly tedious job
of having to implement all of these here
now you can use some of visual studios
features you can also just kind of copy
and paste this and implement everything
it's not the biggest deal in the world
but with visual assist there's an even
easier way which I personally use all
the time which is just right-clicking on
the actual class name here quick actions
and refactorings and then create method
implementations this offers to create
all of the method implementations for
you just at once and if I hit OK you can
see very quickly it's filled in all of
those methods they're ready to go here
and I can just get to writing the rest
of the code for this class which is
amazing ok so I hope you guys enjoyed
that little overview of some of the
things that visual assist offers keep in
mind that this is by no means some kind
of like list of all of the features
visual assist can do a lot more for you
and in fact some of the stuff that I
haven't mentioned you might absolutely
love and in fact if there is a specific
visual assist fascia that I didn't
mention that you use that you love using
please leave a comment below I'll take a
look at it because there's I mean
there's so much individual assess if I
am not even aware about if you've never
used visual assist before I highly
recommend that you give it a try I'll
have a link in the description below to
a 30-day free trial
check it out try it out for yourselves
it's absolutely amazing for me visual
assist and visual studio really go
together when someone asks me what my
favorite IDE is I say visual studio but
really I mean both of them together
I think a big part of why visual studio
is my favorite development environment
is because of visual assist I'm trying
to help you guys out
give it a try let me know what you think
and I will see you next time good bye I
want to wait for you to try visual
assist come on I'm waiting